all right hey what's up everybody
sorry for the delay there's always a
whole bunch of stuff that i got to do
before these streams
a lot to prep to make sure it's as
smooth as possible for you guys
um so once again thanks for joining
thanks for checking out my channel
thanks for being here
with me on a saturday we're going to
learn and grow together that's the whole
point of these things it doesn't matter
what program you're using
it doesn't matter how much knowledge you
have it's it's time to just jump in all
right it's time to jump in and learn
and practice our passion together so
today i i've wanted to do this for a
while
but this tutorial is basically going to
go over how to
track your footage here and and we're
not even going to
comp anything into this footage we're
just using this as camera data
we're going to take this 3d track camera
data
and we're going to build out a 3d scene
and i'm using cinema 4d you can use
whatever you want
we're going to build out that 3d scene
and we're going to use this 3d tracking
data
and apply it to that scene in order to
give it a bit more
realism now obviously i think the faster
way to do this would probably be to
actually hook your your iphone up to
your camera
and do this in unreal engine but i'm not
quite there yet
so we'll you know i'll certainly have a
tutorial on that
later but i still have a lot more
research to do before i can confidently
jump into unreal
and and bring you guys through that
process i don't want it to waste your
time here
um i certainly want to be as pointed as
possible with these
streams so before we jump in though
um just a couple announcements for you
guys the last couple weeks have been
huge
for my channel um thanks to you guys i
really really appreciate it you've
checked out my videos
you've been leaving comments like crazy
um so
i put out my photo reel vfx full vfx
workflow video
and that's got 32k views that means a
lot to me thank you so much
there's a whole bunch of comments in
there and it's an hour long video
um you know it goes through my entire
workflow when i'm comping
like vfx live action um
sorry so many words it goes through my
whole workflow basically when i'm trying
to put in like realistic looking cg
elements in the live action footage
and then i also drop this custom hdri
tutorial video
and unlike the live streams these are
actually you know produced videos that i
took time to edit and whatnot
and it's at 36k you guys are awesome
thank you so much
um and it's full of great comments as
well great questions
um yeah with the custom hdri thing i
released a
hdri pack the link is in the description
and um with the photo reel vfx
yeah yeah i think that that's it that's
all i wanted to say
i just really appreciate all you guys um
stopping by the channel
and helping me out here it means a whole
bunch so if you're not subscribed
already definitely subscribe
and leave a comment what do you guys
want to watch what do you guys want to
see um in the coming streams but
i'll be doing my best as usual you know
you guys are always stopping by here you
guys know how it is
um i'll i'll be watching the chat here
but i'll also be
focusing on on the lesson so i'll do my
best all right
and then also yeah uh there's a weekly
challenge every single week
and that is set up through
basically or ran through the discord
server that i have the link is also in
the description
and we do one every single week i
announce the winners at the end of this
stream at the end of the lesson
and i'll also announce the new weekly
challenge at the end
of this lesson so definitely stick
around
and let's make some cool stuff let's
jump in so
we want to track this footage also a
link in the description
um download link for the footage i've
been playing a lot of last of us
a lot of last of us too and you know
you're squeezing through some dark
tight spaces and that's certainly what i
want to do i have downloaded
all of oh this is this is a mess here
let me let me show you guys
i got all these like barrels
ammo crates boxes let me get rid of the
cloner
and just lay out here what i got this is
all from mega scans and i used
bridge to bring all these assets into
c4d
quickly and easily there are super high
res 8k
textures and oh yeah another crazy bit
of news
guys um i got something
really awesome in the works if you look
very closely
you'll see here i am running a quadro
rtx 6000 with
24 gigs of uh video ram here that is
huge that is so much more than i mean i
was on a uh
you know just a couple months ago i was
on a gtx 1070 and i think that had like
eight gigs of ram and then i got an rtx
2080
and that still had eight gigs of ram but
my goodness three times more
with the quadro rtx 6000 i'm so amped um
and that's
actually we're going to use the power of
this card in this scene we're going to
have a whole bunch of these boxes and
crates we're going to stack these things
up high you ever seen the end of indiana
jones 4
it's basically gonna be like that but
like a real tight narrow corridor that
we're gonna be squeezing through
um and we're gonna light it with some
really cool like old vintage
edison bulbs um so that's that's the
plan
for the stream today but we start with
tracking our footage so
we can do it in after effects with the
after effects uh tracker
let's just run it and see what it does
actually real quick before we run it
i know i'm gonna need i'm getting ahead
of myself
i don't need a jpeg sequence because
we're not comping anything into this
footage
so let's just in after effects i'm just
going to throw a 3d camera tracker
effect on here and let it run
i'm not even going to mess with any of
the settings here i'm just going to see
what it's going to do
and hopefully um this thing is blazing
through
it's only 1280p so or 720p
sorry but how you guys doing
how you guys doing in the chat here
we got some fans from india awesome
welcome guys welcome welcome i
definitely want to visit
at some point that is high on my list
to visit india um very very excited i
got a couple friends out there so it'd
be cool to
visit them and and explore the city
or the country the entire country rather
yes rotobrush 2
it's awesome it's very fast and it's
really cool because you can actually
expand your like
working area so that if you have any
fast moving targets or fast moving
objects
the roto brush will actually be able to
like catch up
and it's a lot more accurate so it looks
like this has tracked our scene
pretty darn well
and i'm just scrubbing through looking
at these points and there's a lit no
it actually looks fine and here's the
thing this doesn't have to be perfect
as long as it's tracked for the most
part like again we're not comping
anything into this footage we're just
taking the camera data
and we're using that so i'm going to go
ahead and lay a
floor plane probably
at this point here so i'm just going to
select
i'll select all these i'll right click
and set ground plane and origin
boom actually let me let me get just
these guys
set ground plane in origin and
let's go ahead and just make some
some uh some solids here so i'm just
gonna hold down
shift and try and select four points
that are kind of in a square
maybe like these these points here right
click
and create a solid and a camera that's
going to give us our solid right there
and if we scrub through we can see that
it's pretty much stuck to the floor
let's go ahead and give ourselves
a wall right here so i'm just going to
select the footage
select the camera tracker and we'll make
a plane
right about here uh we'll make a solid
there
and i'm going to rotate this guy let's
see
let's rotate this guy
up about 90 degrees so i'm holding shift
to rotate it at 90 degrees
and you just want to line everything up
so that your lines are
pointing in the right direction
and this guy we can actually
probably scale and
scale and i
basically just want to optimize our
scene so i want to tell after effects
like where these points are and honestly
i probably don't need to build out all
this geometry
let me think about this for a second i
tend to get ahead of myself in these
streams you know i just keep going
charge full speed ahead but it's nice to
stop and think for a second so
all right i just want to have this when
i bring this into cinema 4d
i want this camera data to be as
easy to work with as possible
so maybe all we need to do
is have our floor i'm going to go ahead
and parent the camera to the floor all
right
and this is going to optimize our scene
so what we'll do i'm going to hit p
and since it is you guys see here if i
make a new solid
and i hit position it's at 640 by 360.
all right so i want to lock in the same
position for
this red solid so 640
by 360 to zero
all right and since the camera is
parented to this floor
nothing's going to change because
they're moving relative to each other
but what happened was basically this is
snapped to the center point so when we
bring this into our 3d space it's going
to be at 0
0. let's mess with the rotation as well
and just
zero everything out and we'll put that
at 270.
all right so that's just going to orient
everything correctly and then as far as
scale goes
a scale is always adjusted in cinema 4d
i have to adjust that no matter what
so let's see here
so i'm i'm honestly yeah i'll mess with
the scale i'll just show you guys
i'm gonna make a new solid and we're
gonna make it 3d
and you'll see it's kind of tiny down
here right so all you want to do
is mess with the scale of your floor and
since
this solid is not parented to the floor
if i hold ctrl
it'll make these numbers slide at a
lower
or a slower rate so you just want to get
this solid
so that it's about the size of your
composition something like that
and then you can just unparent
everything
and every time you make a new 3d layer
it's going to sit perfectly right in the
middle
of your scene so that's a really fast
and easy way to optimize your scene in
after effects and i know that i think
action movie dad put out a plug-in to do
all of that in like two clicks
so definitely check that out okay
so all i need to do is go to file
export maxon cinema4d exporter
and let's do tracking folder
and i'll just call that track and we
should be done
with after effects let me open up
that file that we just exported track
okay cool and if i scrub through
you can see that our footage just
dropped perfectly in and it looks really
nice
so the idea here is we want to build out
a
uh like a little corridor
so if i let's see here if i hop out of
camera view
and we take a look at our 3d track you
can see certainly that's what that's
what happened in real life
i turned a corner um
you know we did a thing and we just need
to build geometry around
all of this so if i spawn
a cube and we do something like this
right and it's going to be a long
corridor because i really want to make
use of this uh this new graphics card
so we're going to fill it with a bunch
of stuff
something like that and then holding
ctrl to duplicate
and r to rotate holding shift to snap
so we have this little corridor that we
built for ourselves
and i'm going to go ahead and just make
all that editable hit t
and let's let's group it
alt g and we'll scale it on the y
and then let's just make a floor and hop
back into camera and see what we got
all right so in the wall we definitely
need to push this back a little bit
so we'll go to top view just to see
what's going on
so i'll push that back a hair perfect
and then um let's see what else do i
want to do
i want to pull up my frame rate
i want to see if i'm getting a decent a
decent frame right here so i'm going to
hit
alt v and that's going to pull up our uh
our viewport options and whatnot so i'll
go to hud and
we want where are you frames per second
and that'll pop up here so we're we're
getting
a great frame right here so we know that
this is a true accurate representation
of you know of time and we come around
this corner and we hug that corner real
tight
awesome so that trick
basically tracking your footage and
using your real camera move as a as a
virtual camera
in a full 3d scene that just kind of
makes your 3d scenes or your 3d
sequences feel a lot more real
and a lot more alive because you're
actually using a real camera
again if you were doing this in unreal
engine you would just hook up your phone
or your ipad to to the program
and you would mount it to just like your
actual camera shoulder mounted camera
and you would walk around your scene in
real time but again since i don't know
unreal
that well yet um
i'm gonna save that tutorial for later
all right how's everyone doing so far
yeah the camera normalization script is
the best
um i hadn't installed it yet i've gotten
pretty quick at just
doing it i've watched this tutorial many
times
um oh strange07
no sound all right can you guys hear me
if you guys can hear me give me a thumbs
up
in the chat
just want to make sure you can hear i
think strange maybe you are
the only one who cannot hear me but
we'll find out
hopefully that's the case
all right
so if we
let's get our scale right we definitely
need to get our scale right
so i always spawn a figure
and the figure would tell us how big our
scene is so
our scene is actually too large right
now because that person
is if i'm five nine i want that person
to be as tall as me
right so what i'll do if i actually
start scaling up
this this null object that has our
camera in it
um it's gonna it's not going to work
correctly
it's going to snap back to its original
position
and it's just not going to be nice so
let me hop out of the camera view
and i'll show you guys how to easily fix
that i'll hide the floor for a second
we want to scale our scene from the
center point so that everything scales
proportionally
but before i do that i want to just drop
this into another null object so i'm
going to hold alt
and select a null and this now is our
camera
and i'll hit l to enable our gizmo and
i'm just going to zero out
the gizmo so it's sitting right there in
the middle so when we scale it it's
scaling from
the ground from zero zero right
so to get this scene um to get the scene
proportionally scaled what we'll do is
we'll go to coordinates and we need to
actually type in the numbers here
we can't scale it up and down it's gonna
or i'm sorry we can't use
the scale tool because it'll just snap
back to its original position it's not
going to work correctly
and you can see there it actually
something happened where it
oh that's the oh never mind that's the
null object okay if i use the scale tool
you can see if i hit play
it's going to drop underground or wait
did it work
does it just randomly work
yeah i'm underground basically
underground now so we don't want to do
that
we want to scale it using these settings
here
in the attributes so we'll do
0.5
and then maybe a little bit so like
point maybe 0.35
something like that and we'll hop in
maybe it's a little big
that feels right maybe 0.375
and now our scene is scaled
proportionally and let's bring our
geometry back in just that's a guide
we're going to build it out with those
boxes
all right so what would be the coolest
setup so like
let's go back into top view and adjust
this
on the fly
all right so i just want to get this
corridor as tight as possible
and we can actually adjust the camera
like the orientation is a little weird
we can adjust that after the fact
and i think i can get this wall a little
bit closer so i want to get it as close
as possible
maybe like there
oh that's nice and it's really good
okay so what we'll do now
let's actually adjust that little that
little camera motion at the end
we want to tilt it up so i think the
best way to do that is to
maybe throw it in
we want to adjust the camera
i wonder what the best way to do this is
we need to tilt the camera up
hmm
let's hide the geometry for now
and figure out the best way to make some
adjustments on the camera
so we want it to be tilted up a bit more
so i'm wondering it looks like
it looks like the entire scene
needs to be angled
up just a little bit so if i
let's see we hit l
we get it about there
and we do something like that i'm
wondering if
that'll even things out a little bit
yeah that's actually not bad so all i
did was just
grab the outermost null object that our
camera is sitting in
and i tilted it up just so that
this line is as straight across the
floor as possible
and i think that did the trick
okay so the next step here we're going
to light this stuff
last first we just want to drop in all
of our barrels and ammo crates and
whatnot right
oh let's definitely save our scene
yeah this is track
all right
i do need a mod yeah i do
oh yeah and um evolver you were right it
also good to see you
um octane is free for blender
100 free for blender okay
let's see here let's hop out of the
camera view and let's set up our scene
let's set up all the barrels and the
crates
so i'm going to copy
this camera and this null this will be
our uh
we'll just call this like our block out
scene here
i'll grab this i'll grab everything in
fact copy it and we're gonna paste it
into
this assets project window or project
file
give it a second to load
all right it's still loading i guess
we might get a crash but that's okay
how long is this usually i go for three
or four hours
on the stream i try and keep everything
again as consistent and precise as
possible
um and i want to make sure that you know
i get through
a complete lesson by the end i don't
want to do like a part one and part two
too much so there's only so much we can
do we can't do crazy things we can't do
big scenes unless there's a part one in
part two
um but for now you know yeah just like
about three four hours sometimes it goes
five hours but today i'm probably gonna
end around two my time
all right so it looks like we're frozen
so let's go ahead and reopen cinema
i'm glad that i uh that i saved
that project that was close
all right so for those of you just
coming in so what we're doing we're
taking
our uh we're taking some footage and
we've tracked it in after effects
i didn't mess with any settings i just
you know threw the default after effects
tracker on there
made a plane on the floor and i'm taking
this tracking data and i'm using it to
animate and navigate around a 3d scene
we're going to build in cinema 4d
so it's a way to make your your cg
scenes and your sequences a bit more
realistic because you're
actually using real camera data and we
just crashed so we're hopping back in
so a quick tip for you guys if you want
to improve your
viewport
frame rate here
a couple tricks that i use first off
oh man okay here we go first
first what i do is i will switch
my my viewport method or my display
method to just
uh shading grout shading versus with
lines
so that's n a and n b those are your
shortcuts
all right so n a gets rid of the lines
also there's n
q and that will nq will basically
uh turn off textures just
in viewport and it's needing a minute to
catch up
because i just opened the scene but
you'll see here on the left
the textures are loading in and
that takes up you know some some memory
in the viewport and if you want to hide
that it's n q
and yeah certainly i'm going to render
this whole thing i want to try and get a
render out and
at least get something that we can see
by the end of the lesson by the end of
this stream so all right so i guess it's
still loading in
don't tell me it froze again yeah we're
good
these are 8k textures again i want to
make use of
this rtx 6000 the new quadro
um so i actually have a deal with
uh with p and y and nvidia
and it's in the works and it's very
exciting and i think
um we got some plans going we got some
plans they sent me this new
quadro rtx 6000 um huge huge huge thanks
to nvidia and pny for working together
to hook this up
um and uh yeah there's some very
exciting plans in the future i'm not
going to give out any details yet
there'll be time for that um there'll be
there'll be some time for that for
details
but i'm going to tell you now that you
guys are going to benefit from it all
right it's going to be very exciting
all right yeah you guys can follow along
with whatever whatever program whatever
renderer anything you want
okay so let's just give this a save
again
enqueue that's going to hide your
textures and make it a lot easier
and quicker in the viewport so let's go
ahead and merge this
with our tracking scene
okay so now what we're doing
is we actually
can actually see what this camera looks
like
when it's moving through 3d space with
some
barrels and crates and stuff oh and we
need to extend
our scene we also need to make sure it's
at 24 frames
per second
and i just want to make sure shift 3 is
your timeline
i just want to make sure that we're
getting all those frames yep we're good
so this is the fun part this is when we
build out our our scene
so we can do this in a number of ways um
we can instance all of these objects and
kind of duplicate them one by one
right which is certainly a way to do it
if you want full control over
over your scene another way to do it
might be to
hmm
i'm wondering if
i'm wondering if we can set up like a
dynamics
situation where we just drop a bunch of
stuff on top of each other
um i'm wondering if that
could work
okay let me let me let me test this
let me test this so
if we um okay
instead of manually placing everything
which is going to take a while
we might have to do that that might be
the the best way to go for the most
control
it certainly is you know the way with
most control
but i think
what we can do is let's make uh let's
make a cube
let's actually take the original
geometry we set up our test geometry and
let's take a look at this one more time
and make sure that this
is right for us
i think what i'll do is have
a crossroads here in the middle that way
we can get some really cool depth
in our scene so by crosswords i mean
i'll just
open that up just a little bit so we
actually get
you know a pathway going off into the
distance and we'll add some fog
it'll be like a foggy basement or
something um
so you they just look like they go on
forever right
these boxes are just stacked high
infinitely that's
the look we want to get so i'm going to
scale this
out i
already i feel like this isn't the way
to do it
in terms of using dynamics to drop
everything on top of each other because
it's gonna fill all
the entire volume of this of this cube
and that's
so much wasted memory
so maybe what we can do is clone
the boxes
hmm
let's try that let's try cloning the
boxes
inside of these cubes maybe on the edges
of the cube or something
um
so let's get the cubes sitting on the
floor
i'm going to grab all three of these or
i'll grab
just the entire null and i'm going to
hop out of the camera so you guys can
see what i'm doing here
i want to get the anchor point at at the
bottom of these things so i'm going to
use the
axis center tool with include children
use all objects and i just want to
execute so that's going to move the
anchor point down to the very bottom of
these cubes
and now i can just zero out the y and
it'll be sitting right on the ground
so it'll look like these are stacked
infinitely
long and infinitely tall
and i'll make a couple more adjustments
here so that it
looks like let's get rid of the floor
for a second
so i just want to scale this out
to give the impression of infinity here
in fact instead of doing that i liked
our angle
so i'm going to actually just grab
these edges here and i'll make sure
only select visible elements unchecked
so i get both of those
and i'll just move that out we'll move
that out
same for these guys we'll just move that
out
and then maybe there's just a small cube
at the end
right there so things can just end there
and we can put a point light back there
to draw the eye to the end
which will be sweet and we'll do the
same here we'll put
a box right at the end holding ctrl to
duplicate
just like that
awesome
so this is our rough scene right here
kind of reminds me of dark souls a
little bit awesome
all right how's everyone doing
yo if you guys spam the chat i might
have to just kick you i might i just
might have to
and you wouldn't want that
so animator pro you best chill out
unless uh unless you want to get the
boot here
because no one wants to see spam in the
chat that's lame
y'all can do it in any program you want
it'll be a good time okay so let's um
let's see here let's take all of these
barrels and these crates
and let's throw it into a cloner so i'm
going to hold ctrl
alt and drop it into this cloner oh
that's a subdivision service definitely
don't want to do that uh oh
undo undo okay that's close
cloner yes now here's the key ingredient
secret sauce
set your clones to uh
set your clones to multi-instance and
that's going to
allow you to duplicate as many um
iterations as as you want and it's not
going to tax your system
so you get to do it for free that's the
way we're going to be able to achieve
this here
so next what we'll do is it's it's
cloning everything
basically just on the floor here we want
to clone it across an object and that's
going to be
this null we're going to clone it across
the null that's all
of uh of our geometry that makes up our
walls and our corridor here so let's do
cloner and we want to set it to object
we'll drop the null into the object
and iterations will be random
and we want let's see
let's hop out of our camera view to see
what's going
on
and i'm going to take these cubes and
we'll hide them
in the viewport so it looks like we're
not getting anything
i don't know why is it because it's
going across the null
or do i need to do this individually
might have to happen individually
unless i take all of this
and i'm trying to just do a one blanket
duplication
let's go ahead and select all that and
we'll connect plus delete objects so now
it's just one piece of geometry
and i'm gonna hide this null
and let's go ahead and grab our cloner
and point it to this new null that we
created
so now it's duplicating
across all of our geometry all these
different boxes
so we definitely need a lot more
certainly
all right
so what we'll do is the count
right we'll set the count to like 1 000.
let's see what that looks like that is
crazy
and we wanted this we want this to be so
dense
that we're not able to see through any
of these walls let's go ahead and change
it from surface
i think surface is what we want
yeah surface is definitely what we want
let's go from a thousand let's try
5000
and let's give the cloner a random
modifier
so we'll make sure the random is in the
effectors there
we'll uncheck position let's hop into
our camera
wow that's intense all right let's take
it from five thousand
let's take it to ten thousand
let's take it to thirty thousand
and you can see we're actually still
getting nice
a good frame rate
so this is like the blanketed version
this is how we just want to like
blast it with as uh with as little time
as possible but get
some kind of result i don't i feel like
this isn't gonna be the way to do this
i think we're gonna have to place these
things
manually let's try a hundred thousand
i mean we're here we can do it
and my frame rate is still above 24
that's incredible
but you can start to see this is kind of
kind of the vibe
but we're definitely inside
of these crates and everything let's try
200 000
and now our frame rate is right around
24.
but we're inside of these walls so
hey evolver thank you for the super chat
i appreciate you brother
um means a lot thanks for stopping by
thanks for taking the time i know you're
busy dude
but i'll see you around man thank you
and no san francisco prince yet um
but it is definitely on the list so i
will let you know for sure
okay
so i'm wondering yeah i feel like these
need to be manually placed
and here's how we're going to do it and
keep cost low
all right let's go ahead and uncheck the
cloner
let's hop out of our camera and let's
set up an instance for each one of these
objects
so i'll bring everything out of the
cloner
just like this okay and let's
um
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to select each one
we should be able to select one at a
time uh reuben jack what's up bro what's
going on
thanks for the super chat man appreciate
you thank you guys
it means a lot um a lot of work goes
into setting up these streams
um especially since then i do them on
the weekend um
it's the only time i i have to do them
so
the super chats definitely help it makes
it like
an extra level of worth you know to
keeping this stuff going
it helps out a lot
all right so we want to set up our
hallway
full of these boxes and we want to do it
by
instancing each one of these so it
doesn't destroy our system
we want to keep cost low so we're going
to select it and we're going to
go to let's say hold down this
subdivision surface button and we'll let
go on instance
all right and i'm just going to do that
actually can i
i'll do that for each one
oh man i'm getting lost here okay which
one container s yep
box s i think i did this other one twice
other m yes this one
that's m we're on s
container m
and these are all from mega scans
ported over with bridge a fantastic
tool i don't know what i'd do without
them
i'm going to select all of these and the
instance mode i'm going to set to
multi-instance all right and now
every time we duplicate these instances
um
we're getting them for free right we're
not having to spend all of our ram
on duplicating the actual geometry so
i'm going to just uh
put all this here into something like uh
we'll just call that crates
this is our crate instances
so yeah you guys are asking about the
tablet this thing is the best
it saves my wrist a whole lot um and
that's what this glove is
so i can like glide across my wacom
tablet easily
um and yeah i mean it definitely
i'm using this every day so i want to
save my wrist for as long as possible
if this if this wrist goes i got to
start using this wrist now and it's
going to take
a couple months to get used to you know
so i just want to make sure i'm as
staying as safe and as healthy as
possible when working
and i really do love it i'm very used to
it now
okay so we want to clone all these
instances across
our scene here so i'm going to build
this up
bit by bit here
i'm wondering if i can actually
pile some of these on top of each other
maybe
and do it in chunks because one by one i
feel like it's gonna be really really
tough
so maybe what we do
so we take these instances
and we build out like four different
like
why can't i see them
all right so i'm going to render our
scene and see what we got
and let's do
i got a name on my stuff all right this
is a
base geometry and i'm going to put
everything
into a geometry folder
and the octane sky i'm going to put into
a scene folder
all right so i'm just kind of confused
on
this instancing here
so if i want to instance this bit this
crate right here
um i feel like i just need to
yeah that's correct
multi-instance makes it go away for some
reason
render instance keeps it in the scene
okay so i'm going to undo
and just set these to render instance
and we'll hide the original crates i'll
call these original crates
and then now we have our crate instances
that we can duplicate
to our heart's extent and not have to
worry about losing any
any ram or anything her memory so let's
maybe build out
four chunks that we can duplicate on top
of each other
have fun bye-bye
really
love you but
so apparently uh my cat ate my
girlfriend's yoga mat
not good it was an expensive yoga mat
too
okay let's make four blocks of crates
here
all right so what we'll do is i'm just
going to control drag all these out
and just build it out this will probably
be the most tedious part of the process
and we'll just make them like
maybe we'll stack them like a crisscross
style
like this
maybe grab this guy here
something like that you can see how
they're all about the same size which is
good for us
that way we can just start stacking
things on top
i'm going to duplicate this guy out here
this is the longest part for sure
am i don't even know what to say about
that i don't know what to say
all right i'm just gonna duplicate this
guy back here
boom
and then this tiny box maybe we can we
can stack
onto this point
and i'm just holding ctrl to copy all
these things
and i definitely want to give it a bit
of like
staggered kind of a staggered effect
that way the light will
will really play nicely on all this
stuff
all right so we're gonna do a a second
row
here where this will just sit right on
top
something like this
maybe i'll save that big guy for last
awesome so we have like a number of
barrels here maybe i'll grab
this one
bring it to the edge
so this will be like our first pile
and we'll make maybe two more of these
and then we'll duplicate these across
everything
yeah that should do
so i'll hide the camera select all of
these crates
and we'll group those
and call this uh
cluster one
um ayan i uh
make a car animation maybe you know i'll
see
i kind of do what i what i just feel
like doing on the day
i have a very small list of things to do
in the future on the streams
so i could add to the list for sure if i
can find a good reason to do it then i
will
but that's a good good uh
good recommendation um assume it
wow thank you thank you so much
says you love my energy to motivate and
teach us new things
absolutely i'm glad you guys are down to
learn
so that's the whole point of all this
for those of you just joining to learn
and grow together
and grow in our passions together right
and keep practicing consistently
practice because if you add up
all of those days where you practice if
you do it every single day
and you add that up to a month to a year
you're going to have 365 days where you
have put in practice
and that's going to add up for a decade
and
eventually a lifetime and you'll truly
be a master of your craft
um and am thank you again appreciate you
sweet hi from iran that's awesome my
vacation was great it was very relaxing
and peaceful
all right man gotta
gotta silence a lot of people today a
lot of nasty comments
a lot of spammy comments
okay so let's take all of these
instances
maybe in ctrl drag it up
and i'll rotate it
90 degrees
something like that
and maybe they can switch so that
this the first ones on the ground i just
want to keep this as
randomized as possible
something like that
feels pretty good maybe
we get like this big guy in here
and that'll make it more of a box shape
that feels right
maybe a little bit more 25.
so again this will just be duplicated
over and over
to build out our hallway of ammo crates
maybe we grab one of these little
barrels here and we put it put it up
here or something
we'll scale it down
hey i really appreciate you guys i
really do
thanks for keeping it positive thanks
for keeping it
fun all right
let's maybe grab this guy this wooden
box
it's like legos it's like cg legos you
know
that's what i love so much about all
this
let's give it a save hopefully doesn't
crash on us
yeah i got that rtx 6000 um
pny and nvidia we're all teaming up
together they sent me one of these rtx
6000s and it is working like a dream
um and we're going to be working on
something very cool in the future
for you guys so definitely stick around
for that
you do not want to miss it i promise
very very very excited there's some
really good people over there guys
some really solid people
and we just need more people like that
in the world
all right so there's our first first
chunk
let's build out one with these big guys
here
so let's try and keep
yeah let's maybe do a round that's like
a few of these
across
and we just want to randomly kind of
rotate these a little bit maybe we'll
keep the end ones straight
but the ones in the middle will randomly
rotate around
and move forward and back and just give
it a bit of random
randomness to the whole thing
something like this and then we'll
duplicate the last one there
something like that so we have all these
crates
and we can probably take this middle one
and we can flip it upside down just to
get
randomness out of this
right about there cool
and then let's go ahead and stack a
bunch of these guys
across
and we'll throw in some of these
military crates too
like that cool
get those to sit yeah perfect just like
that
and we'll duplicate these on the other
sides
about there and we can kind of fill
in everything if i
duplicate and rotate around
and we'll try and pack it in tight here
same on this side holding ctrl to
duplicate
and flip these guys around
so yeah my vacation it was awesome i
went to nevada
and i went kayaking for the first time
it was really cool it was very peaceful
and very chill it was definitely like
one of the chillest things i've ever
done
so i definitely want to go kayaking
again
i almost came to the point where i
bought one just because it was so chill
but
i think that i'll have to wait because
there's not any lakes around us here in
california
what else did i do i went on a utv
that's a atv but like the car
version um so that was really cool
we just like tore up through them
through the mountains
brought some snacks we brought some like
grapes and stuff you know just chilling
with some grapes it was a good time
i don't think we need that middle one
awesome so that's that we'll stack it
one more we'll go more on top of that
actually i think that can just be its
own deal that'll be its own little setup
so now let's do one with like these
barrels
let's just stack a whole bunch of
barrels
and i think i can do this with a
a cloner so let's grab this instance
here
and hold alt select the cloner and i'll
just bring these
in together
just like that okay and then i'm gonna
give it
um
let's go ahead and give this
a random modifier or a random effector
okay and i'll turn off position we'll
just mess with rotation i believe
yeah x rotation i'll set that to 1080 so
they're all just kind of randomly
rotated around
different points so that's cool we'll do
that
[Music]
let's take these small guys i'm gonna
control drag these guys out i'm gonna
hold
ctrl alt
let's see let's
bring them to center or now reset psr
i'll take the ammo crate i'll lay it on
its side
so these are all about as tall as each
other
or rather i can scale this ammo crate
down
i'll do like 0.9
0.85 i want to get them pretty uniform
um let's do center axis tool
y to zero that didn't work
i'll just bring that down to the ground
manually
about there and now they're roughly all
the same size
height wise
and i'll select those three control alt
put them in a cloner
like that and then um i want to set the
cloner to random
and that will randomize how these guys
are laid out
and then i'll do a random effector again
we'll uncheck position and we'll put it
on
rotation randomly rotate these guys
and we'll also do position i'll zero
them out first
and i'll just do one and one
and try and bring these a little closer
together
something like that and we can stack it
on top of each other three times
see this is why it's tough to do with
the cloner is because they're not
actually touching each other you'd have
to go in
and use dynamics to get them
to fit um
oh sumit you want to learn character
creation man i don't know i
i don't uh i don't really know too much
about character creation that's not my
forte
but it means a lot that you want to
learn it from me man
i think for me as far as character
creation goes i can like pick out
characters that look cool
you know and then use that as a
reference to make my own that's probably
where i would start
so to make um this worth our while
so we didn't just waste time doing this
let's actually get this going with some
dynamics so we can
use this in our scene so
i'll bring out a floor i'll make the
floor
let's give it a simulation collider body
okay
so that's going to ensure that when
these
crates drop they're going to stop on the
floor
just like in real life and then i'll
right click our cloner we'll simulate
with a
rigid body tag make sure you save
go to frame 0 and hit play and those
will just fall perfectly
very nice um let's see if we can't start
it out a little closer to the floor so
they don't bounce all crazy
something like that
and maybe we set the random position
back to zero
and they're sitting yeah they're sitting
like something like that
but i feel like maybe the rotation the
random rotation
we can amp up a little bit more
because these boxes are pretty uniform
let's just try 360.
that's not bad so now we have a cluster
of like ammo crates and stuff
but we want to take the dynamics tag off
of it so
let's see let's go to
create instances they were at the bottom
all right
and we want to click our dynamics tag
we'll set this as our initial state so
if we go to frame 0 they're going to
they're going to stay like this at frame
0. and then i think we're in
the boat where we can just
maybe delete the dynamics tag nope that
doesn't work um
go to frame one frame four delete the
dynamics tag no that doesn't work
let's try baking it so i'm gonna hit
ctrl d we'll go to dynamics
cache will bake it all right so now
that's baked
um let's try it again undoing until
let's see we'll go to uh control d again
clear the cache go back to frame zero
bake why are they starting up top like
this
clear the bake
[Music]
let's see set initial state
let's bake that so weird why is it doing
that
so frame one
we'll start them out that way let's try
if we just go negative two
so weird
shoot why
hmm i want to remove the dynamics tag
because i don't want these to be dynamic
anymore i am only using the dynamics tag
to get them to sit on top of each other
once i do that i can get rid of the
dynamics tag altogether
but for some reason
so for some reason it's
it's not baking properly
all right let's try it let's try it
the set initial state i feel like should
do it
set initial oh clear initial state maybe
we'll go forward we'll set that
hmm yeah not working just let the damage
tag
oh not enabled yeah enabled off
yo hey good tip there really really good
tip there who was that
poison yeah so poinsen said
to just disable disable the dynamics tag
um but leave it on that's a good tip
that's a really good tip
all right we're almost there we're
almost ready when we can just like start
stacking all this stuff together
so that's our little ammo crate
bit there we have our
oh let's take our barrels
and give it a position effector or a
random position
so we want to do x and y
so a little bit like that and a little
bit like that
two and two yeah that's good
sweet
we'll build one more stack of crates and
then we'll call it a day
so let's try this again with the cloner
so let's grab
that guy let's try and grab
all of these
we'll control drag these out we will
reset psr
so all these guys right here
we'll drop those into a cloner
and we want to get them pretty tight
together
see that's the issue is that
these boxes are different sizes
and they're just not stacked properly
yeah i feel like that's not the way
all right let's check back in with the
chat here how's everybody doing
so you guys are asking for other
tutorials and other programs
um i to be honest i probably won't do
any blender tutorials i won't do any
maya tutorials
i'm going to do tutorials with what i
use
with the programs that i use unreal
engine is the only
program right now that i'm learning and
trying to get the hang of
so that will be the only like new
addition in terms of new tutorials
i do lots of cinema 4d i should do more
after effects
um but yeah like i'm not going to learn
a whole a whole new tutorial like
blenderguru
is putting out the best stuff ian hubert
is putting out the best stuff
for blender right so there's no need
those guys are crushing the game right
now
all right we'll do let's just try
duplicating this
and we'll randomly rotate
these guys let's do it by
no position all rotation 1080.
boom so that's like a nice cluster of uh
of barrels there
and we'll do one last one
so let's grab this coffin looking thing
we'll grab this guy let's grab this guy
this military crate
let's slip this guy in here
you
this is the most tedious part guys
building out these assets
but pretty soon we're going to drop it
into
um not this footage but we'll drop it
into
the camera data we got from this footage
and then we'll light it really cool i
can't wait to light this i can see it in
my head so
very very excited
oh wicked uh thanks for hanging in there
man that's intense
hopefully i can get you a nice rendered
frame a lit frame like maybe
in an hour we're almost there
we're going to start lighting all this
stuff it's going to look really nice
i'm just building out this last little
chunk
and the reason we can duplicate all of
these
these meshes here and these are all 8k
textures is because we're doing it with
a render instance
if we were to do it any other way we
would be destroying our system
it also helps that i got this uh this
new graphics card from nvidia
they hooked it up um with tmy we're
teaming up we're doing
some cool stuff together so definitely
stick around guys you do not want to
miss out
on the awesomeness it's gonna be some
cool stuff for you guys
i know i keep saying it but i'm excited
i'm super excited about it
all right how do we want to build out
this bit maybe we do um
some more of these crates
sweet
perfect perfect
and what i'll do is i'll make bigger
blocks
with these blocks here
and we'll duplicate those
awesome awesome so excited
this is going to look so good
you
and i want to break up these objects as
much as possible
i don't want any like duplicated
kind of looks going on here
and as long as these can like stack on
top of each other
to some level then we'll be all right
ctrl shift z will undo camera moves
it's a really handy tip there
so right now i'm listening to my
um ambient playlist on spotify on my
bone phones here
there's also a link or there should be a
link to that in the description
if not um
if not then i know it's in one of my
older
stream videos so maybe keep this window
open
and go find it and come back
turn it on and vibe out with me here
because
it's pretty chill i'm not gonna lie it's
super chill
all right i think this is good so i'm
gonna start grouping all this stuff
together
cluster 2.
let's take these barrels here
let's
remove one of them so it'll
fit in here with these guys
so i'm actually gonna put
i'm gonna put them on one side like this
and i'll randomly rotate them around
like that perfect
so this will be
cluster three
i think we said this was our cluster one
this guy will be cluster four
cluster five
and i think that's it
so this is what we got we made all these
stacks
and now what we'll want to do is stack
all these on top of each other
to make our corridor
now i'm wondering if we can actually
i'm wondering if we can use dynamics
to stack them
like if i broke up actually i have an
idea if i broke up cluster
three into
two parts
so like this would be one part right
that way everything would roughly be
cubes
like right about there
so that will be its own deal
cluster five or six cluster six
so now we have all of these like
very similar shaped bits
and i bet you we can take this one
and we can clone this
again
so we'll do four by four or two by two
and we'll set it to uh
render instance
and we'll stop stack it one more time
and we'll randomly rotate these as well
and maybe we'll also give this a
simulation tag rigid body
and we'll let it drop whoa
it's because it's set to multi let's set
it to or rendering let's just set it to
normal instance
there we go and let's uh
set initial state go back to frame 0 and
we'll turn dynamics off
and this is our cluster 5. so that way
it's a
we can actually fit it in with the rest
of this it's all the same shape
so now we're at a point where we can
start
really having fun okay so
i wonder
is it possible to
[Music]
do the dynamics trick with these here
with these objects here
but i know that dynamics can't be done
with render instances
hmm so maybe what we'll do is we'll just
use a cloner
because they're all basically the same
size roughly
and we can start stacking them
all right let's bring back in
our test geometry
let me drop all these random effectors
in into geometry
effectors sweet
and we'll put all the clusters into uh
final
cluster setup
ah everybody doing okay thumbs up if you
guys are hanging in there
and following along we're about to build
out our final scene apply our camera
data that we tracked already
and we're gonna light it that's gonna be
the best part it all comes together in
the end
broken absolutely man i really enjoy
these live streams they're fun i learn a
lot while doing them
i'm glad you're getting value from it
i'm glad you're enjoying uh
enjoying all this from albania man
that's a ways away heck yeah
all right let's do our base geometry
we'll bring that
back
and i'll zoom out let's set the base
geometry what's the easiest way to do
this
if we set the base geometry to x-ray
maybe i'll select all the cubes hit
x-ray
i also feel like
i feel like we can scale it down too
just so we can like just get a better
sense of where we're at
all right so i'm wondering if we just
need to set up
very specifically this first area in
here
and then we can um we can kind of clone
everything else
i'm betting we can do that so let's
start
with
specifically setting up
the area that the camera is very very
close to okay
so i'll take the final cluster setup
and i'm just going to start duplicating
it and since they're all instances it's
totally fine we don't have to worry
about
over taxing our system or anything like
that
cluster three let's go ahead and
reset the
the anchor point
i think we can just hit l and get it
right there in the middle that's totally
fine
oh cluster three
um has cluster six inside of it i think
it does
yeah there we go
so let's bring our camera back in and
see
where it starts all right right about
there
so we don't worry about any point behind
there
all right let's see what it looks like
ah so excited i'm so excited to light
this
cool very cool christian what's up dude
been a minute um
man how was the well-deserved holiday it
was great man i got a lot of chance to
read
and go kayaking and and ride my onewheel
it was an awesome time i actually
finished this book here
which of course i got on cue boom the
5am club
this book is incredible it's all about
starting your day at
uh at 5 00 a.m and the first 20 minutes
are spent working out really hard
the next 20 minutes are spent either
meditating in silence
doing yoga like just a mental rest
or setting up your day journaling right
and then the last
the last 20 minutes are spent learning
so for me i'm watching unreal tutorials
right now
and the idea is that if you set up your
day in a way that
allows you to tackle the heart mind
soul and body and you do that every
single day for the rest of your life
then you're going to be about the most
efficient maxed out version of yourself
as possible
so that's certainly what i'm trying to
implement i don't want to let anything
slip i don't want anything slide so
i got a lot of work to do a lot of hard
work to do
so i just want to make sure that uh i'm
putting in the effort that's needed to
accomplish all the things i want to
accomplish because i have a lot of goals
um and i'm very excited
so um i feel like we're missing
something
where did did i delete cluster six
i did i straight up deleted cluster six
no good don't do that definitely don't
do that
so this is the last bit of tediousness
we need to worry about
because once we get um
this intro bit done or the area that
we're really going to be focusing and
seeing our main elements
then we can actually like work and focus
on
just just duplicating all these up the
stack we don't have to worry about all
the detailed stuff in the background
we'll just let it duplicate
and it'll be totally fine
so duplicating cluster one i'm going to
rotate it
just a little bit
we'll get it right there on the corner
this is getting awesome
all right let's see what it looks like
sweet
yeah this is gonna be good this is gonna
be really good i'm so amped
so amped the lighting is going to be
really nice
all right let's take this
and the crates so cluster three and four
or actually wait
so cluster three
so holding ctrl i'm going to duplicate
that
oh there's actually more in there sweet
okay so it was three four and
six
these ammo crates
i feel like aren't my favorite element
so i'm gonna make sure that they start
out like right in the foreground
and they leave quickly so if we go into
camera view we can see
there's a bunch of ammo crates there and
maybe
that's even a bit too much so
we might want to get those like maybe
those will be the second layer
and we'll do
we'll do this stuff we'll do like
cluster one will copy over here
and we'll do another cluster on here
again i want to make sure that you can't
tell
that this is duplicated
so i only always want to be mixing up
the way i'm stacking all these elements
and the best thing is we have four sides
to each one of these so technically
there's four different looks we can get
from one stack
and it'd be cool if they were kind of
looming in
teetering in from above
oh yeah this is feeling good i'm very
excited about this
you
so this is kind of inspired partly
because i've been playing a lot of last
of us
um but it's also inspired by
my vacation a little bit because we went
into this antique
store and it was
something else it was packed so tight
with just like crap
and it was dimly lit and that's
certainly the way i'm gonna be lighting
this
very dim um and very cramped
oh this is gonna be so good i'm legit
excited about this
and again the reason we can do all of
these materials these are all 8k
materials going here is because they're
instanced
we only have to load it once that's it
awesome very very cool
let's just render it and see what we got
yeah we'll definitely throw some fog in
there no doubt
don't worry there will be fog
oh a big loading container like a
shipping container that could be cool
um i don't really have access to a
shipping container right now
um but you know that's okay
that's all good and i want to keep it in
this like wood theme too
guys look how smoothly this is running
oh my goodness
this is insane this new rtx
6k is really crushing it
yeah this is gonna be sweet
we'll get it top lit
i think i have a toplet hdr let me find
one real quick
just just while we're looking at the
render or testing it
so this this actually i'm using my
warzone pack
um that i created i'm sure you guys can
pick that up
on gumroad it's like eight bucks and
it's just a bunch of different like uh
battlefield um set hdris so we got like
stuff in a plane fuselage destroyed
fuselage we got um a field full of
barrels
um you know we got a junkyard we got
sewers
it's a good time yeah we got a nasty old
crawl space
oh this could be cool let me set it up
so that we're getting lit from the front
here
that's awesome
melanie what's up yeah the streams are
back
back from vacation
but yeah this looks ooh this is gonna
look so good i'm so excited
that is wonderful
oh maybe what i'll do is i'll add a
flashlight
as well i think that could be really
really cool
i'm just impressed that the frame rate
like is still good um
[Music]
with all of the different assets we're
using is really really awesome
okay i might switch out these barrels
for
maybe i don't know because they're like
right in view
this is when you're art directing your
scene here
what do you want the audience to see
ours yo what's up dude or not ours
armando
i appreciate you man thank you the super
chat is very very welcome
uh thank you thank you you're the best
thanks for the help and training
i made for us i've learned a lot from
you yay that's awesome dude
let's keep going let's keep learning
every saturday just for you guys this is
awesome
you guys make me happy heck yeah
yeah no we're going to get up with
directional light dude do not worry
we're going to top light it
um with some edison bulbs i got these
guys queued up
uh let me show you real quick
right here we're going to light it with
these hanging from above
so that's gonna be super chill it's
gonna be all top lit and nice
so don't you worry my friend it's gonna
look good
okay
back to it back to it where are we at
assets yes
i'll pause the render for now and we'll
keep building out our scene
what's up henry yo man glad you're
enjoying the stream
means a lot um yeah vacation was chill
man
i really appreciate everybody everybody
asking
yeah vacation was great very peaceful
all right holding control duplicating
this and remember
guys we have four sides four different
looks
to each one of these cubes so make sure
to rotate them around all right
and the best part is we can move all
these individual bits
this is completely adjustable
that is the very best part we can remove
any little pieces that we want
you
we can fill in the gaps too later
very nice we might be close to the point
where we can actually
start duplicating or start cloning these
cubes
in these clusters
i think we are
i think i'll add one more stack um
one more vertical stack to these last
two here
and then i'll do uh probably one more
vertical stack i'll do one more vertical
stack to everything in the foreground
i need to add one here and then i need
to add two more back there okay
and then we can just duplicate
everything out
i can't wait to get a floor going too
ooh it's gonna look nice
yeah and all the assets are from uh mega
scans
the very best this is like the greatest
so nice
i'm seriously like my heart is beating
so fast because i am
so excited to light this
all right and then we'll just add two
more stacks
back here so i'll grab
these guys and just clone them back here
and maybe i'll give it a little bit of
like turn to it
so it kind of like disappears around the
corner
see what that looks like
oh that is so cool
yeah i just needs to keep going
oh these ammo crates got reset somehow
that sucks
dang what happened
yeah that dynamics thing not the best
i wonder if it's because i deleted the
floor
dang everything got reset the whole
thing got reset
just floating uh
but i think wait are these ones good
nope
so you just have to make sure that like
nothing looks duplicated and i've said
this multiple times here
but it's just very important that's
what's taking the most time
so what got started with with uh or what
got me started with
vfx great question
so um basically
let me just make sure my floor is
correct here
so basically um my buddy bobby
he came over one day and i asked them he
brought his video camera right
and i asked him how does a video camera
work like
how how does how do the movies cut from
one image to another that blew my mind i
didn't understand it
and he showed me he rolled over here he
cut and he rolled over here and he
played back and he showed the cut and i
was like what the heck
that is awesome so what he did
or basically from there he told me hey
you have a windows movie maker
on your computer you can create
you can edit movies if you want to make
movies and i was like dude
that sounds awesome um thank you
for letting me know about that and
my brother at the time had a like a
really
new digital camera it was like a small
little cheap thing but it was brand new
as a digital camera and it had a video
mode on it
so i took that and i just started
filming dumb stuff like i had a bunch of
airsoft guns so i filmed
little airsoft shorts and whatnot and i
started adding
uh like muzzle flashes to individual
frames and i would save it out
in macromedia fireworks they're not
around anymore but
that's kind of how i got started with
all that
and i basically i discovered video
copilot
and that was the point when i was like
okay this is legit
this is really cool that you can create
all these things i want to learn more
so you know i just learned a whole bunch
through andrew kramer
in all of his tutorials um
and a friend on youtube he sent me a
copy of after effects
when i couldn't get it so that was very
very kind of him
and i basically got addicted to learning
because when i moved
from california to georgia
i i mean currently i'm back in la but
when i i originally moved right
from california from yeah from
california to georgia
and i didn't have any friends i didn't
really know anybody so i spent most my
time learning
learning learning learning i learned as
much as i possibly could
and that is basically how i got addicted
to learning
and filmmaking and visual effects
so it's been a fun ride let's get let's
stack these up taller
these need to continue stacking so
let's get like this
i believe yep we can get those we'll
rotate them
just a little bit
and we'll get those right in there
and we want to stack these guys too
right in front of us
so we'll stack those up
you
these guys don't need to be perfect
because they are in the background
well we're almost on the lighting my
favorite part
it's really gonna make this shine
hey what's up sodamonte everyone say
hello to sotomante he's one of
um he's actually the first moderator on
the discord server
and he's done a really good job of
building it up to what it is today so
definitely give sotomante a wave a clap
a high five something just let him know
that you guys
appreciate and support him um
he's been doing cool stuff in the server
making it really nice
for you guys so shout outs shout outs to
my man
sotomontay
all right guys we're at the point like
there's there's this little empty space
back here
let's fill it with something because
everything there is no place to hide in
this place here it is only
boxes and crap let's raise it up
there it is
sweet
so the rest of this i think
can just be duplicated back here so
here's what we'll do
we'll hop out of camera view this is our
scene
i'm going to grab a actually we already
have it it's in our geometry
and it's in our base geometry
let's hide the plane for a second
and it's these two bits
actually three bits here as well
and actually be cool if this opened up
so
let's move this right up to that corner
this will get right up to the corner
there
and if this opened up a little bit
so if i use the axis center tool and
move it
negative z plus x
will leave y at zero it should go right
into the corner
right in there yeah and we'll do the
same with this guy
it's just going to be plus x minus z oh
wait no i got that wrong
it is plus z
plus x yep and it goes right into that
corner
and we can rotate it on that point
and just open it up a little bit
just like that and we'll take
the base geometry and we'll scale it up
just like that and we'll make sure that
oh weird something happened what
happened oh it's just not lined up
so we'll want to make sure oh cause we
scaled it from
right now that shouldn't that should be
fine there it is
yeah that's going to be sweet okay
yeah the basement where you've lost
something and you need to find it
what's the left tag on the octane sky
that is a very handy plugin
called uh hdri link and that allows you
to just
launch hdri browser it's a grayscale
gorilla plug-in
and yeah it basically allows you to
search through all your different hdris
all the different packs
this is all from grayscale gorilla
except for my warzone pack here
and you can do custom stuff so that
that's the coolest part is you can like
these are custom this is uh
what is this manhattan knights these are
night hdris so it allows you to easily
browse everything it'd be really cool to
um i'll reach out i'll reach out to them
because they actually sponsored one of
the weekly challenges
and they gave out their everyday
materials collection as a prize for you
guys
um to the top five winners so maybe i'll
reach out and i'll ask them hey
would you guys be down to maybe uh drop
another cinema 4d plugin or something
it's it'll be nice though for prizes to
be
programmed not program specific you know
what i mean
but anyway just an idea so here's what
we're going to do we're going to clone
all this stuff across
these bits here so
what is the smartest way to do this
let's take our base geometry
and
we'll make it as high as it needs to go
0.75 is that the max
yeah it looks like 0.75 all right that's
the max so we don't want to make it any
higher than that
um and then we can also
take our edges in to the point where
just where we need them right because we
don't want to fill this entire thing
with boxes and crates we just want to
fill the section we need with boxes and
crates
so just a sliver maybe just that
same for this one we just need a sliver
and technically
these edges can come down
so now when we look through our camera
it looks the same
but we have a lot less space to fill so
we just want to save that
save that data now what we'll do
all right let's let's go to our final
cluster setup let's grab one of each one
two
four five three four five six here we go
so i'm going to hold ctrl
drag these out this is everything we're
working with right here i'm going to
reset the psr on this
drag them out again and
we should be able
so just move these out
they should all be on the ground
some of these are not let's just make
that adjustment
weird i don't know why that's not
working um let me try something let me
grab those five
we'll reset psr again and i'll center
that axis
weird okay so it's still it's still not
doing what we need it to do
let me undo everything
and we'll just try that again
we want to make sure that the axis is in
the middle of all these guys
i don't know why it's not working
properly
like it should
yeah that's in the middle cool that's in
the middle that's
right in the middle i just want to line
these up
we're getting set up to clone them right
and now we'll go to our front view
and just make sure that they're all
sitting on the ground
so we'll get the anchor points all
correct
cool now we can zero out
we can zero out all these models and
they'll they should be
sitting on the floor right at
what the heck
why is the floor not the floor oh that's
confusing
anyway
yeah that is weird it's probably because
they're in these nulls
there's like 12 knolls inside of all
inside of each other
there we go all right so now they're
sitting on the ground and
now we will clone them so these five
yo martin thank you sir
wow much appreciated
thank you thank you martin we're almost
there we're almost to uh
to lighting should be fun
all right
why is the floor not the floor who knows
okay
let's take all this let's clone it i'm
holding ctrl alt
and i'm gonna pop it into a cloner so
instead of cloning them
in a grid i'm going to clone them based
off of an
object the object will be
one of these cubes so we'll go to
um crate in
no base geometry let's grab one of these
cubes
and that will be god dang it where to go
there it is cloner
cube one
wonderful okay so we just want it to be
cloned
once along this bit so if i just make
that a flat plane
move it over a little bit that's all we
need okay
so now when we clone this let's set the
iteration
the clones we'll set it to random and
then we'll take
the instance we'll set it to
render instance
or we can even do multi-instance i think
and then
tell it to it's only showing a certain
percentage
i think
but i think we're good with render we're
good with render instance
so you see how they're all rotated like
that we certainly don't want that so up
vector we can set the plus y
and they'll just sit normally and we
don't want it on the surface actually do
we want it on the surface we want it on
the volume
and if we just crank the count
um
[Music]
now there should be a way to do this uh
surface
we set it to like 300.
or maybe what we should do i feel like
this isn't working for us
um
maybe what we could do
is clone it as
a grid like we have here okay
and we'll just stretch out
we'll stretch it out like this
in fact we want it to be a per step
so we need to type in the number that
touches these as close together as
possible
so 100 is probably where we want to be
yeah and we want to get to the point
where it's the same on the
on the z cool
works for me and then
i think we can set this to like 15
maybe 20 right so that gets that's
the length of our hallway and then
we will also
set the height to
let's start with 2 for now and work this
in
right so let's go ahead and
get it so it's just sitting flush that's
actually pretty dang perfect
it's a little off
maybe 35 is a good middle ground
there's definitely some space in some of
these
but i think that's okay i think it'll be
hidden so 35 let's say like
38 36.
um melanie yo thank you thank you for
the super chat
heck yeah you say glad to hear you had a
good
holiday i hope you could rest up and
recharge any chance i can get feedback
from you on a couple photographs i took
with lessons in mind i learned on your
previous streams
absolutely absolutely melanie if you
want to
go ahead and
message me on discord do you have
discord melanie if so just send me a
message on discord and i'll happily
critique
anything you have absolutely thank you
so much
your your birthday super chat last
two weeks i guess was absolutely
incredible thank you so much i had a
very nice meal with that so
thank you thank you
okay let's keep going so i know i want
less barrels
there's too many barrels so what i'll do
let's turn off the cloner find which one
is the barrel
this one here okay there's too many of
them so that's cluster four
let's let's duplicate everything that
isn't cluster four
so now we have a lot less barrels
so it's duplicating everything twice
except for the barrels right
it's only duplicating the barrels once
and let's see what else we can adjust on
this i would love
to rotate
um each one of these elements
but randomly i want to randomly rotate
them
by 90 degrees
i know that you can do it with a
linear cloner so maybe that's the way to
go on this
maybe we linearly linearly clone
um negative what is it negative x so
it'll be
100
and we do it 25 times
maybe just 20.
all right so we have all these little
assets and we want to
randomly rotate them
by 90 degrees
so i think let's see
if we go to transform
see that does everything um i know
there's a way
shoot i'm trying to think i know there's
a way to do this
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
you see how this rotates everything
randomly
on its own i want to do that
on the correct axis i just feel like
[Music]
hmm
because i could just bust out a a random
uh
a random effector yeah with the position
going we can set that to like three
y will be zero and that'll be three
rotation we can set
see this randomly rotates everything but
i only want it to be in like 45 degree
or 90 degree little snaps
so i don't want any 45 degree nonsense
i'm just looking for
perfectly aligned little bits here
but snapped at 90 degrees
oh is that it modify clone
no um that's changing the clone out
give them their own pivot point but here
no here's the thing is like
i see how these two are clones of each
other i want this to be randomly rotated
like in a different direction
i'm not doing a good job of explaining
myself
my brain is a little dead here i want to
rotate this
on a north south east west kind of set
up
individually controlled um
i think the random rotator is probably
the best bet i have of doing this
but you just see how they're all like
randomly as like skewed
i want them to be lined up as close as
possible
yeah so i wanted to look like this but
just randomly snapped
hmm
i wonder if i can do it with a step
but instead of scale its rotation
it's kind of like this but more so
um
[Music]
maybe if i change out this spline so
it's going in steps
oh wow i got some math going here um i
wish i could just draw it
yeah it's not quite doing what i wanted
to do
i think it's okay i think we'll just
have to deal with it
oh snap all right let's try it
formula effector with 90 degree set to
parameter formula all right man this is
intense
all right formula effector
um
formula factor with 90 degree set to
parameter
and this in formula
did that do it yo it did it
what the heck that was so fast yeah look
these are both clones of each other
right this one and this one
but they're randomly rotated
wow yeah so 180 would work
360 would work that's so good
i think it's doing it is it doing it
720 or it has to be like uh
yeah that's totally working that's
amazing
you can see these are this is the same
clone but they're rotated differently
and snapped exactly to 90.
whoa that was next level i go by zach
zach
thank you crazy
dang i don't know anything about that
that's that is good
so that's exactly what i need um i'm
wondering if
i can just set this cloner back to
[Music]
a grid array
i think that's doing it man
the formula effector is certainly
working
so cool so let's line this up
this needs to be stacked up
oh because it's doing it from the center
point there um
awesome dude this is awesome
let's group this
get our anchor point down to zero
and we'll slide it over the corner
let's hop into camera view real quick
and we need to get this thing over
right there awesome
okay so now what i want to do is a
little too uniform
let's rotate this thing
yep that's good it's a little too
uniform so we'll go with the random
effector
on our cloner
grab that guy and we want
this to be like this
popping in and out like that wonderful
very nice yes a lot of geometry
look at that frame rate it's above 24.
it's because i got that brand new rtx
quadro
6000 running right now it is
crushing this scene like no problem
big shout out to pny and nvidia
nvidia sent me out this card it's about
the fifth time i said it on the stream
but hey i'm very happy you guys made me
very happy so thank you nvidia
pny is a collaboration we're teaming up
together
we're gonna do some cool stuff for you
guys um in the coming
months so get ready no details yet but
get ready alright that's all i'm saying
dude this is looking good um
let's duplicate this holding ctrl moving
it over
and i'm just going to rotate it
a little bit more very nice
cool
all right so we want to make sure it's
on the floor
we can get rid of this cube and
let's go ahead and
make sure let's see let's check our
cloner
render instances yeah
we can turn off textures by hitting nq
and now our frame rate's below 24
finally
and i'll just drop in that last little
chunk
back here um to wrap it out so let's hop
out of camera
jeez
that is crazy
absolutely crazy
so we'll duplicate the null holding
control
and let's adjust the cloner settings
so everything goes back to one actually
the height will stay the same the height
will stay at 30.
let's get that down to two and let's get
that at like
six maybe and we'll just cap it off
right at the end here
and we'll do a cool thing like uh
actually no we'll just do it with
lighting we'll do it with lighting it's
going to be great
yo that's a good idea luggage lost by
tsa
that's really funny
so you can do a thing where you go to
display and you set everything to
what is it box
yeah our frame rate's still it's at 10.
but let's light this thing let's let's
take a look at this little bit
here and see how we can improve
the lighting
and last thing last thing before i do
that i'm going to just rotate this
camera just a bit
i want to tilt it up
right at this moment
so maybe what i'll do is i'll go to
camera i'm going to solo it
i'll hop out of it
and okay yeah so it's right in the
middle
um let's move the anchor point so it's
in line with the camera
right about there and i just want to
rotate this
up like that
so that should
allow us to see a bit more
oh
that was close
sweet all right um
let's light this thing
all right let's render it and see what
we got actually before we do that
i'm going to take
the hdri and i'm just going to set it to
a color i'm going to set it to black
so we're just in a black void and we'll
render and hopefully we'll see
nothing and then we'll start dropping in
lights i don't know if we have enough
time to do the edison bulbs
i would love to i just i have to be
somewhere at three o'clock i'm gonna be
a little bit late to that
already as is um
but we'll see what we can do here i
certainly don't want to cheat this i
want this to be as good as possible
okay
so
let's start dropping in some lights
i'll just make an octane area light and
it already looks super creepy
so what i'll do is i'll go to uh options
and i'll uncheck camera
so i can actually hop out of my camera
here
and let's just clean this up so i'm
gonna hit enqueue to get rid of the
textures
n d i believe no no nc
we'll have it so that there's no
lighting in your viewport
we'll scale this down
and we want to get an ies light
and that's basically a light profile um
that looks like a realistic light
and that's the vibe this is what we want
right here
oh wow that's incredible
that is super creepy
i love it
so you can just pop that light in a
cloner
and set it to linear
and minus x so it'd be every
i don't know every 100 100 inches
maybe every 20 feet 20 feet
and we'll just have it go so it'll be
like uh
10 times all right so that doesn't look
right
why is that not right let me render it
again
yep totally indiana jones vibes 100
so it's thinking it's thinking
very hard
and for some reason oh
let's turn check camera back on
for some reason we're not seeing things
so i wonder if that's because
all right let's troubleshoot this a
little bit
so it's these last three nulls
render instance is it multi-instance no
what about just instance is it gonna
break all right so that's everything
we're seeing everything at this point
and we'll adjust our lights
oh there it is okay i'm just trying to
get him like lined up with the corridor
a bit more
and we can take the lights and we can
hide them
so they're not camera visible
or maybe what we do is we bring them up
so let's just take the cloner up like
20 feet
and it looks like it's being blocked so
i'm going to uncheck the camera
hop out and see what's going on
okay they went the wrong way
we'll bring them way up here
man this is yeah this is uh this is a
delicate process i don't want to rush
this
let's take the lights um
maybe here's what we'll do here's we
still need
we need to do this right let me actually
hop into a new
file here a new project file
and
i have my hdri set up i'll zero it out
so it's just darkness okay
let's find a floor
concrete floor
um
[Music]
dusty concrete floor this seems
appropriate
let's go ahead and download this
so this is a qixel bridge
it allows us to download all the mega
scans assets very easily and transport
them to
whatever program you're working in very
quickly so you guys will see here
you've probably seen this a million
times
yeah the lights are probably not
directional enough so i'm going to
actually do this the right way
with an ies profile so they look legit
and thanks for sticking around guys
means a lot
we're gonna make some cool stuff here
this definitely needs uh
definitely needs a careful uh careful
attention to detail with the lighting
here because all of our work would be
for no reason
all right we'll go to export settings 8k
cinema 4d yeah
let's uh let's export this
and it's going to transfer into our
scene
very quickly
by very quickly i mean it's going to
load for a second
it's just a lot it's a lot faster than
manually inputting everything
there it is
you
cool all right so we got
our floor down here looks nice
so let's mess around with some lights
here what we need to do
is we make an octane area light we'll
point it at the ground
raise it up and in texture i believe
we're going to load an image
and they're free online you can find
them everywhere online but they're
called ies
profiles okay and you get an idea here
of what they can do
so basically um these images show you
what they look like
so number two is a good one right
because that's a very like top down
spotty kind of look and
you know maybe this one number 8 can be
cool
so i'll load that in and it's going to
if i turn
the hdri back on take our plane and
scale it up
if you make this light small enough i
believe is it small enough or big enough
small enough and let's try uh cranking
the settings on this
so we should get some sort of profile
here if i set it up against a wall
let me ctrl drag this
so i feel like this isn't right
hmm
let me try let me try another one let me
see if it's just that one
oh it's because okay i need to make an
ies light i need to do
octane um shift c will search anything
ies light in octane
great and i'll choose my profile number
two
there we go
but why is it not
oh that's because god dang it
uh i use the wrong one okay that's
that's a cinema 4d wanting to use an
octane one so let's try that again
so i had to make sure i used you have to
switch over to ies right here
in the main you go ies and you load it
into distribution
and there we go you can start to see
this ies profile takes shape
right might look like a flashlight or
something so that's the idea that's what
we want to go for
um and if we have a person about that
big
we want to find a profile that actually
looks really cool in a large scale
setting like we have
so there you get an idea of how this
works
and i believe you can change the
temperature yep
definitely go for a warmer feel uh 4200
that feels about right to me
so you can change that profile if you
want if you want to go with something
brighter
or you know maybe something a little
different
let's try four
that could be cool
let's try that so i'm going to copy this
light
and we'll go into our scene here
and let's paste it into
this cloner so now it's switched out our
lights
let's hop back into camera
render it and see what we got
and i agree volumetric lighting is gonna
crush
um it's what this needs
certainly so while that renders i'm just
going to
let a friend know i'm going to be a
little behind so yeah actually guys
so after this i'm headed into hollywood
and i'm going to join up with a good
friend mark edward harris he's a
professional photographer
travel photographer and he put out a
book called the way of the japanese bath
it's absolutely incredible it blew me
away
i bought it right when i saw it it was
so cool and i'm going to be joining him
in hollywood
and interviewing him over the next
couple hours
and asking him questions like you know
what are some awesome tips that you can
give to the audience and i'll be doing
that on instagram so
um if you guys want to follow along on
instagram i'm at
underscore or i'm sorry yeah at
underscore punisher
underscore i'll type it in here so you
guys can see
so that's me on instagram um
let's mess with this lighting
dude i feel like fog would totally just
mess this whole thing up
it's gonna be ridiculous
yeah i think the lighting here needs to
be very specifically tailored
i've been playing a lot of last of us so
i don't want to skip
out on the lighting here like it's it's
really going to make or break this
let's hop in here and let's maybe set
our lighting up for the first bit
so here let's set this up and i'll
probably
i'll probably have to bounce after i set
up the lighting for this first bit here
but i'm going to keep working on this
because this is
really nice
let's back out
and we'll get a spotlight right in the
center here
we want to draw the eye into the
background
and have the background lit in such a
way
oh that's really cool
but i feel like
we turn this down
and we hold ctrl we're going to
duplicate it and put it behind the
camera too
so it fills in that negative space
and we'll do it again
and this light i feel like will be the
brightest so maybe we take that middle
light and take it
to like 200
maybe that's 300 this one here
is 200 and then that last one will be
500
and let's let's drop our floor in
because it's going to really help us
i just want this to feel large
so one tip for setting lights is you can
select the light go to camera
use camera and then set active object as
camera
and now you are the light your viewport
is the light
so you just navigate around
and i want to blast this
with a spotlight
to give a cool effect here if i back
this off and turn
it way up like
turn it up to like two thousand
ten thousand
maybe that's too much
maybe i should just go with like that
top light look
and i definitely feel like volumetric
lighting
needs to happen so we'll probably add a
bit of fog in here as well
i'm going to drag our
floor texture in
and i want to just clear out any of the
textures that we're not using
let's see let's go materials
remove unused materials oh actually
before we do that i want to apply
the floor material that we just
transferred over
and now cinema is frozen oh we're back
we're back
yup dust particles certainly would be
very nice
gross that floor looks horrible
how do we make it better um
let's move this light up
and take a look at our floor let's uh
zoom in on here
and i think we just need to adjust the
projection
so i'll give it a projection node and
i'll pipe this into everything
we'll set up the box
and we'll take transform and we'll set
it to like 0.2
it's really hard to see let me crank
this
up
maybe we set it to 0.01
or 0.1 and that feels
a bit better let me take this to glossy
octane
yeah much better
so this is really dark here there's no
fill light so i certainly want
to fill this out um and i think i'll do
so
with a soft light
from behind here
that just looks really cool that's
awesome
so i'll spawn in octane light
set the temperature to 4200
hop back into camera and we'll turn it
way down
let's take it to zero first and let's
maybe try 20.
i feel like that's still a little much
we'll try
10.
that feels a bit better and let's
do let's see
let's mess with our camera a bit here
so i think it'd be nice to have some
depth of field
so we'll drop that down
let's take an aperture of like uh 1.8
2.8
3.5 i just want to have a little bit
little blurry here in the foreground
that feels good but it still looks
um i feel like we need to shape the
light more so
so what we could do
is try and blast these lights a little
harder
so this is our fill light
that actually looks pretty nice
and if we remove the fill light we just
set it to like two
and what i like to do when i light is
turn them all off and turn them on one
by one and see what we get
so that's directing the eye that's
leading the eye
to that backspace there
this light is doing nothing what is this
light
let's delete that okay so we have this
light is our
um background light
this is our like mid-ground
situation here
and this is our fill so if we fill it
just a little bit
we have this mid-ground hit right here
and our background i feel like that
lights it a bit too much
so maybe we take our mid ground and we
take it way down to like
500 or or 250 or something
so our eye is drawn to the background
and
let's maybe turn up
that background light to like three
thousand
and i'll just kind of rotate it around
to see
[Music]
what it looks like
now i'd love to do a little bit of bloom
as well
oh man that looks cool too though
so our background light if instead of
zeroing it out maybe we bring it to like
50.
and we take our mid-ground light and
really blast it
that's interesting as well
so that's like our fill and then we have
actually no
our fill would be the light that is
filling the shadows and then this is
like the
key light
so let's mess more with our camera
let's set this two and three that's
gonna give us like a bokeh kind of a
look
and let's go and
we need to check camera to see this
all right that color profile really
makes it difficult
to see
oh man that is super cool
oh maybe if we have a light shining
from this point here onto the wall
like here or something
so we can duplicate one of these lights
this key light maybe
yeah come on
we'll take that
man this is crazy
we'll copy it drag it back scoot it down
get in close and rotate it so it's
facing
this wall and we get a nice beam of
light
like hitting basically hitting these
stacks right here
just like that
that's interesting
freaking 2fps yeah it's it's nuts right
now
let's go back to the camera
and work in some post-processing
so this is just going to hit the
brightest points
and give them like a nice bloom so let's
see if i can can't
crank something up here
oh that's like some exterior light like
you're going outside but i feel like
that's not the right vibe
just red
yes i'm just messing with a lot of stuff
i feel like it's a good way to
get a look you know is is to really go
through a bunch of different iterations
and find out the one that you enjoy
so let's see if we can't max out this
bloom
there it is okay
nice so it's just those highlights are
hitting that bloom right there
nice and subtle keep it subtle
and then certainly you know giving it
some fog would
make it feel real nice too
man i feel like there's so much story
stuff you can add to this
um so i'm not i could do aces here
um oh wow there's even more
oh wait it looks like it's all doubled
up
um but i i don't i feel
don't really feel the need to get into
aces right now it's a very
complicated setup um i'm still learning
it
man that yeah this is this is looking
really cool
let's just take a peek around the corner
and see what it looks like
we'll add motion blur to this too
god that light okay yeah that's intense
um i think i'm just going to give this a
render while i leave and see what it
looks like
because this could be really really
sweet um
i'm gonna make sure i get rid of this
light because it's very blinding and
very intense
certainly know what we're going for so
key light the second one
i'll take visibility and just knock it
out
or maybe
we set it to like 0.1 0.01
or we just move it up a little bit
yeah that's cool
so yeah i think i'm going to give this a
render but i'm gonna come back and keep
lighting this because
i definitely want this to look as good
as possible
um and it needs that detail precision
work
to get that look so i'm gonna set up
motion blur real quick
um let's do
one over 60
centered make sure we save
geography or geometry we'll give it an
octane tag so it accepts the motion blur
we'll throw our plane into that as our
floor
let's set up the render the place where
it's going to render
yep 1280 by 720 certainly
all frames
32-bit exrs we don't need alpha channel
and i'll give it a save here um i'll be
sure to post this test
in the discord server for you guys so
you can see what's going on i'm going to
keep working on it though
because it deserves the attention
so we'll just call this uh
test v1
with
1200 samples
and we'll give it a render
and see how long it takes for a frame
um while that's going i think it's time
to finally announce
the winners of last week's weekly
challenge i was on vacation but i still
got the challenge out to you guys the
prompt was storm all right it was a
difficult one
a very very difficult one um
but let's go ahead and take a look at
all of the entries not all the entries
just the five winners that's who we're
looking at today guys
and then i'm going to announce this
week's weekly challenge
so let's see here
let's find these winners i know i got
them saved somewhere
boom here we go alright so first up
the first winner of this week's weekly
challenge
prompted with storm is blaster jacks
with this awesome image i think you used
blender i think you said
um yeah you got your boat here you got
some boxes and
some nice emissive lightning uh strikes
here with the
with the lighthouse in the background
now this rain is is this dude this rain
look at these cylinders come on look at
these cylinders man
but uh it's not a bad technique not a
bad technique at all maybe could have
given them like a
a water texture at least something
um i thought that was funny though nice
technique
this is cool i really dig this image um
you know i think more work could have
gone in you could have used some texture
on the boat of course
and take this to the max
i think you would benefit from that come
out with a nicer image but i really like
the vibe of this
so blasterjacks you are a winner of this
week's weekly challenge congratulations
to you brother
next up we have gold
with this image here absolutely
incredible
this is basically uh based off of the
game
inside if you guys know that game it's
absolutely incredible you should play it
it's like four or five hours such an
amazing
experience and i love your take on this
gold this is a really nice take on the
storm prompt
um you know you guys know how to get me
with the fog and the silhouettes going
off into the background i dig it a lot
so
gold congratulations i love your
composition i love the lighting
all good here man fantastic work
next up the next winner is
david katz with this image here
this is really nice man a lot of detail
work went into this i can tell
um your background is super cool it
looks like that's almost like a painting
or something back here
and then you have your foreground with
the rocks some steps
maybe some mega scans assets in here i
like your character
so here's what i would do
i feel like you can push and pull the
highlights and shadows on this image i
also feel like you can work on your
color
in the background it's a lot of colors
going on you have blue
there's probably some purple i'm color
blind
there is this green here there's orange
there's a lot going on a lot of colors
going on this background i would
simplify the colors of the background
and also push
the contrast so i would make this a
little bit brighter
and maybe spotlight your guy just a
little bit more because he blends in
but overall i really like this i think
it's super cool it's detailed
there's work you put a lot of work into
this so
congratulations to you uh david katz
for winning this week's weekly challenge
all right
next up two more guys there's two more
we got
night man comet nightman cometh
i think that nightman cometh i think is
your name um with this image here this
is awesome
very nice it looks like you use blender
maybe i'm taking guesses
um this is really fun man like you put
this together i love your
color composition you got the orange and
the and the blue going on
i think this is really good you got a
nice wet ground texture going
my two gripes with this image it looks
like the dude's floating
and it looks like your um your trash can
is floating
that's it that's all i have to say um
otherwise i really dig it man i like
what you put into this
i like the composition i love the colors
so congratulations to you uh nightman
cometh or nightman comment i don't know
that's
probably nightmare cometh
congratulations your winner of this
week's weekly challenge
and last up the last winner of this
week's weekly challenge
is um
what is it sharp aluminum flavor
yes with this image here
very fun it's a post-apocalyptic scene
you got your nice wet ground here a nice
battle destroyed
area in the mid ground and a really
intense
cyclone going on in the background with
lightning strikes going into it
again with the color you got the orange
you got the blue i just know where the
orange is coming from maybe if you put
some street lights in there
it would justify it um
yeah super creepy lightning i i'm not
digging this overlay you put on top
um like some subtle film grain would be
nice
but i think this is a bit too much um
what else it looks like this is an
eyeball here i can't really tell what
this is
i would i might clean that up a bit um
get rid of that
but i like your silhouette it's a good
silhouette
nice destroyed car we got two destroyed
cars here
um but yeah congratulations oh a sharp
aluminum flavor you're a winner of this
week's weekly challenge
you guys did a really good job this this
prompt was difficult
it was very difficult i know um
so i really appreciate all the hard work
you guys put in
and let's talk about this week's weekly
challenge because
um guys like i said i'm working together
with p and y and nvidia and we're gonna
do something really cool together for
you guys so definitely
keep up keep coming to these streams
there's gonna be some cool stuff coming
um so this week's weekly challenge all
right
i am open to suggestions let's start
bringing them in to the chat here and
see what we got going on
um because i like taking requests from
you guys it makes it a little bit easier
on me
one less thing to do while i prep for
the stream
so i'll check in we're getting 30 second
frames that is not bad
i'm excited i am very excited for this
heck yeah um we'll let this go i'ma run
off
to hollywood and take some photos with
my buddy mark
i'll be on instagram he'll be dropping
his photography tips for you guys he's
working on his new series
it's called naked hollywood if you look
up mark edward harris
check him out he's an awesome
photographer he inspired me a lot
so it's really cool to get the chance to
go down and shoot with him
um so catch me on instagram that's
underscore punisher underscore i'll be
dropping some stuff on there on my
stories
so let's take a look let's take a look
at these props
cute oh cute is not bad
castle holograms floral we did flowers i
think we did potted plant
in the past robots we've done
archery it's very specific pokemon
hmm pokemon is good i'm a big fan of
pokemon
vintage technology oh that's good
dang that's good vintage technology
that's a tough one
yeah that does sound cool
ruins vintage electronics or something
abstract abstract could be interesting
i think right now it's between vintage
technology and abstract
oh low poly is good too
okay i'm calling it we're gonna vote
for abstract
let's go um
let's see if we can get like a a little
vote
going um
abstract is one
vintage technology is two
and three is um
[Music]
god dang what was three abstract
vintage technology and uh low poly
what do you guys think no spamming this
is the honor system
don't spam it
all right lots of twos
okay two it is vintage technology that
is
the challenge for this week all right
so what are the rules um
wow what vintage technology what would
vintage technology be i guess it could
be some like fallout 3 style stuff
um it could be like
type i guess a typewriter is counted as
vintage technology
it's going to be tough so what we don't
wanna do is just download an asset from
mega scans or from turbosquid or
whatever
and light it and call it a thing right
you wanna actually try and build a scene
from it you wanna if you can build your
own
build your own thing build your own
vintage technology
render it make it look really nice the
the quality
the lighting basically everything comes
into play into the final image and i
decide the final
renders based off of the ones that look
the nicest if they have a little bit of
story that goes a long way
there's a lot of things that come into a
render like the first thing when i'm
looking through
i'm looking for something that looks
nice does it look nice
if it looks nice i look i look deeper i
look more
and that sets apart um when you get when
you when you basically get past the does
it look nice part
i get into are you telling a story um
what kind of techniques are you using
um you know like how's your lighting i
get into the specifics of it but it's
got to look nice so make it make it look
nice
all right um vintage technology yeah
that's the way to go heck yeah alright
guys so i'm going to post that in the
discord server
um but i gotta run here i gotta meet up
with mark
and i'll see you guys next week okay
next week vintage technology get on it
it's gonna be fun all right guys peace
i'm gonna post this render in the
discord server
when i get back so definitely keep a
shout out or keep a shout out
i've been talking for four hours
straight guys
keep your eyes peeled for that so i'll
see you guys next time
peace